[Music]
g'day today's lecture is called
visualizing extraordinary ways to
multiply and let's do just that the
mathematics we've discussed so far has
been addition adding quantities
subtraction adding negative quantities
and some ratios and proportions which is
a form of multiplication and we went
extraordinarily far with just those
ideas looking at and sorting some tricky
problems last time but now let's go
head-to-head with multiplication and
explore some work that I guarantee or
delight us and surprise us in fact let's
start on the tabletop today and let me
show you something extraordinarily
quirky okay now for something quirky
let's workout 21 times 32 but in a very
unusual way I'm going to do something
called the line method I'm gonna draw
lots of lines first number 21 I'm going
to do is draw two vertical lines for the
number two and then space away one
vertical line the number 121 and for 32
I'm gonna draw three horizontal lines 1
2 3 4 30 and then you get it to hold on
the line for the remaining digit of two
great now what I'm going to do is the
following in this very strange quirky
method I'm going to look at intersection
points example right here in the top
left region I see six intersection
points I see three here I see all here
and I see in the final corner just two
all right grand and here comes the weird
part I'm going to add up these
intersection points diagonally these are
both this here's one diagonal well not
much maybe the stick
points I have right here but this
diagonal has three and then four three
and four to make seven and then this
diagonal has just two and I get six
seven two I claim twenty-one times 32 is
672 and do you know what it is whoa
that's another one but that's that's
weird that is quirky let's do a bigger
one this time let's do say I know one
thirty one times either one 22 all right
so I'm going to draw one line three
lines one line or vertical so one line
three lines and then one line there's
the number 131 next is 122
so it'll be one line two lines and then
two lines yes 122 I said all right so
131 and 122 let's look at intersections
okay
there's nine modules of intersections
that splodge to the single point there's
three up here in the top middle position
one on the top right to there six here
right in the middle two on the middle
right 2/3 up that's gives me six and two
grand
now add up these points diagonally on
this diagonal there's one on this
diagonal there's 3 & 2 X 5 on this table
there's 1 & 6 & 2
that makes nine there's 2 & 6
that makes 8 and on this diagonal
there's 2 1 5 9 8 - and that is a deed
to the product of 131 and 122 haha ok
there is one caveat a problem can occur
look at this one for example
let's do 34 times 21 all right
okay I'm gonna be sloppy now just draw
them the lines by hand here's three
lines and four lines for 34 and here's
two lines and one line for 21 okay so
far so good
you've got the rhythm now intersection
points 1 2 3 4 5 6 1 2 3 & 4 5 6 7 8 are
1 2 3 & 1 2 3 4 and add up diagonally no
problem 6 here are 6 & 3 8 & 3 makes 11
and 4 makes 4 so how do I read this
because 611 T for a little bit weird but
actually I'm claiming this is 611 10 so
actually what we should do now is have
carry one of these cans leave one behind
and make this 7 I claim actually that
carry we're now correct the arts of 714
absolutely crazy all right let's try
this one it has a little bit of a glitch
102 times 31 right 1 0 to draw one line
draw 0 lines and we've done it for
nothing and then draw two lines but I'm
little worried about the spacing here so
I'll do is I'll draw like a dashed line
which means it's not really aligned as a
space fair one zero two and then 31 okay
and we count intersections again this
was grand 3 or how many sections are
here remember this is not a line so zero
intersections there there are 6 here 1 0
& 2
ok head up diagonally there's three
there's none and one there's six and
none and there's two three one six two
3162 isn't it beautiful
it's just weird I have no idea what's
going on I have no idea why this works
but let me point out something to you
that even the standard traditional
algorithm we learn in school at face
value is actually equally weird as this
example look what we do in schools for a
problem like amo 37 times 23 now we are
so familiar with this algorithm that's
hard for us to get that it's actually
weird so just to get you know what it is
begin how familiar it is just see it at
face value
step number one 37 times 23 now I was
taught to read left to right but in this
algorithm you don't do that
you start on the right about you start
with 23 at the bottom and start with the
3 and so so we go 3 times 7 is 21
ok 21 but you know later by 21 you only
have to write the 1 part and then do
something strange you write little two
up here weird okay and then you pause
for a moment
this is strange there you go 3 times 3
is 9 and then now you decide add this 2
to it and write in get 11 which you are
about to write so we do you write it you
write it somewhere strange you write it
next to this one
see that's right 11 now okay now I'm
getting confused for sure and then you
do something like place a zero because I
remember back in my day I totally put a
zero there now okay sure not sure why
and then you go two times seven is 14
I'm lighter right 14 mi now you can only
write the four throw out a four and then
I have to put the one somewhere else oh
maybe you're taught to cross that two
out and put a one there now something
gets very strange and then you go three
times three here's six okay six there's
that one floating around so you make it
seven and now with I write the seven
okay I guess I'll write it here ha
alright if that's not weird enough now
you end this multiplication problem with
an addition problem you add these and
I'll get eight oops
Adam mistake because we have to do it
right to left as well not left to right
okay right to left not like how we read
you go one
zero is 1 1 plus 4 is 5 billion euro 1 4
7 is 8 and that's the answer now this I
admit is very familiar to us and it
feels like we understand it but I'm not
sure if we really do because actually
it's face value this is bizarre if that
I think this is as equally bizarre as
this method both very strange if you can
stare at them for what they really are
so that's our job next let's see if we
can actually make sense of both
algorithms and don't forget our young
students are probably looking at the
traditional algorithm the same way that
we're looking at this one right now this
is foreign and strange to us that's
foreign and strange to our young
students and we allow ourselves to think
about it you know what they're right it
is foreign and strange so let's see if
really makes sense of both of these all
right on to that task all right let's
think about multiplication as I
mentioned in the opening lecture
multiplication to me is a problem in
geometry when someone asked me to
compute 17 times 18 say I think area I'm
being asked to find the area of a
rectangle that is 17 units wide and 18
units high and I think heavens those
numbers 17 and 18 they're hard
so let's avoid hard work and split those
numbers into more manageable pieces for
example we can think of 17 as 10 plus 7
and 18 as 10 plus 8 so this means we're
thinking of dividing the rectangle into
four pieces and it's easy for me to work
out the areas of the individual pieces
10 times 10 gives a piece of area 107
times 10 a piece of area 70 10 times 8
piece of area 80 and 7 times 8 a piece
of area 56 so the area of the rectangle
17 times 18 must equal 100% e plus 80
plus 56 let's see that's 100 and 150 and
56 that makes 306 and that's it the
visuals make it clear what to do by the
way people like to believe that
multiplication is commutative
that is that the order one computer
product does not matter eighteen times
seventeen apparently gives the same
answer as seventeen times 18 well the
visual makes it clear why this is so
just turn our seventeen by eighteen
rectangle ninety degrees and we suddenly
see an eighteen by seventeen rectangle
the area of the rectangle hasn't changed
so the answers to the two multiplication
problems just have to be the same here's
another example
342 times twenty-three and again it's an
area problem now our picture here is
very long and skinny so if you don't
mind let me just walk the picture into
one that won't be drawn to scale anymore
but it still makes it easier to see the
individual parts of the rectangle we'll
make sure that the arithmetic is still
correct in the diagram so let's break
the rectangle into manageable pieces and
my brain sinks 340 and 2 for 240 2 + 20
+ 3 for 23 alright now I can work out
the areas of the individual pieces of
the rectangle quite easily I see a piece
of area 6000 another 800 4900 hundred
twenty and there's a piece of area six
the area of the rectangle must be the
sum of these values but before I compute
the sum let me just point out that
there's some lovely structure in this
picture the piece of the rectangle line
up diagonally by the thousands hundreds
tens and ones so we have six thousand
plus 800 and 900 making 1740 and 120
making 160 which is 1610 and we have six
thus 342 times 23 is 6,000 plus 1700
plus 160 plus 6 and that turns out to be
seven thousand eight hundred and
sixty-six I now let's compare this to
the line method I introduced earlier we
draw three lines four lines and two
lines to the number twenty and forty two
and two lines and three lines for the
number 23 and then count intersection
points
we add up those counts diagonally and
read of the answer in terms of thousands
hundreds of tens and ones in fact look
at the two methods side by side for a
moment in the rectangle we computed 300
times 20 to get 6,000 in the top left
corner and then the line method we
computed 3 times 2 to get 6 intersection
points in the top left corner in the
rectangle in the bottom left corner we
computed
300 times 3 to get 900 in the line
method we computed 3 times 3 to get 9
intersection points in the bottom left
corner the computations are identical
throughout the rectangle method keeps
track of the thousands hundreds and tens
and ones as we go along and the line
method just ignores the thousands
hundreds tens and ones at first but then
it adds up the results diagonally by
keeping the thousand hundreds of tens
and ones back in mind just as it should
so it says that the line method is just
encoding all the information of the
rectangle and so it's really doing
correct multiplication after all in fact
we can see that the standard algorithm
we all learned in school is just the
rectangle method in disguise too
sometimes longer multiplication is
taught in a less compact form for
example for 342 times 23 we write 2
times 3 equals 6 then we look at 4 times
3 but no it's really 40 times 3 so write
down the answer 120 then we look at 3
times 3 but note it's really 300 times 3
and write down 900 and so on this
version of long modifications we can see
is just the same as the rectangle
listing all the pieces and adding them
it just doesn't draw the rectangle
itself that's all now the compact
version of long multiplication is
designed to save space it writes all the
immediate computations on top of one
another and it's actually quite
confusing
make sure is as follows 3 times 2 is 6
which we write 3 times 4 is really 3
times 40 which equals 120 that's 2 tens
which we write and 1 100 which we delay
writing until we work out with look at
the hundreds
now we fish it off this first row by
doing three times three but this is
really three times three hundred so the
answers
nine hundred but we still have the 100
we hold off writing down
so we really have ten hundreds so let's
now write ten in a same row for ten
hundreds all right now I'll do the same
thing again two times two is really 20
times two so let's put it in a zero to
catch the idea that we're now working
with tens 20 times 2 is 40 that's 4 10
so we write 4 in the tens place
20 times 40 is 800 so we write 8 in the
hundreds place
20 times 300 is 6000 3 right 6 in the
thousands place
now add up all the pieces and get 7,000
866 again as the final answer but you
know what that is hard that is way hurt
my brain hood even just try to describe
that process it's so much easier just to
do the rectangle in fact the compact
version of long modification was taught
for the days when pencil and paper
supplies were precious and use up little
room and gets the same answer in the end
I actually prefer the rectangle method
if ever I have to compute a complicated
product I have no shame whatsoever in
taking the time to just draw a rectangle
say rectangle method is actually rich
with understanding we can use explain an
age-old question it's this one why in
mathematics is negative x negative
computers as positive all right so let's
get there and to do so let's check all
the other possibilities first I think
we're okay with positive times positive
example 2 times 3 is usually interpreted
as 2 groups of 3 that makes 6 positive 6
great and I think we're okay with
positive times negative 2 times negative
3 is two groups of negative 3 and that
would be negative 6 things are a bit
shaky with negative times positive
say negative 2 times 3 the idea of
negative 2 groups of 3 really doesn't
make sense but there is a way
out of this pickle earlier we said that
we like to believe that multiplication
is commutative that is you can switch
the order in which the multiplication
problem is computed and be sure to get
to the same answer in the end and most
people feel there should be true of all
numbers including negative ones so if we
wish to take that belief we can switch
the order of negative two times three
and think of it as three times negative
two and that is something we can
interpret three groups of negative two
makes negative six all right so where
are we positive times positive is
positive got it
positive times negative is negative
great negative times positive is
negative sure thing now comes the big
one what's negative times negative for
example what's negative two times
negative three
hmm now switching the order this time
doesn't help negative three times
negative two is just as confusing as
negative two times negative three so we
need something more to do here
well we said something earlier there was
actually quite deep most people like to
believe that all the usual rules of this
particular one is familiar it should
hold for all types of numbers even
negative ones and this means that the
arithmetic that is encoded in our area
model should hold for negative numbers
as well even though geometry does not
allow objects have negative lengths the
arithmetic pictures with negative side
lengths represent should still be valid
as statements in arithmetic let me show
you what I mean here's our picture 217
times 18 remember the answer is 306
but let's be quirky and change how we
think of 17 instead think of it as 10
plus 7 let's now think of it as 20 plus
negative 3 now as a piece of geometry
this is strange I admit that but look at
the arithmetic we have 20 times 10
equals 200 we have 20 times 8 equals 160
we have negative 3 times 10 which we can
do negative times positive is negative
so the answer is negative 30 and we have
negative 3 times 8 giving negative 24 we
get 200
plus 160 plus negative 30 plus negative
24 and that's 306 again just as it
should be
so the strange geometry picture is still
representing correct arithmetic grand or
it can't be quoted with the number 18
consid think of it as 20 plus negative 2
and we still get 306 10 times 20 is 207
times 20 is 140 10 times negative 2 is
negative 27 times negative 2 is negative
14 yep those pieces add to 306 okay so
let's now do the ultimate of quirkiness
let's write 17 as 20 and negative 3 and
18 as 20 and negative 2 simultaneously
and what do we get all right well 20
times 20 is 420 times negative 2 is
negative 40 negative 3 times 20 is
negative 60 so far so good and now we
see we have a problem we need to work
out negative 2 times negative 3 or
negative 3 times negative 2 depending
where you want look at it it's the
negative times negative issue all right
take a pause here just prior to all this
we worked out 17 times 18 three
different ways and got the answer 306
each and every time so if we want
mathematics to be consistent then we
should get the answer 306 in this fourth
example to in which case we see that we
have no choice but to declare negative 3
times negative 2 to be positive 6 so if
we choose to believe that all numbers
including negative ones obey the
standard rules of arithmetic then for
consistent mathematics we have no choice
but to set negative times negative to be
positive but math just wants this to be
slow all right so let's end off today
with something fun
a fun application of multiplying
negative numbers and that application is
going to be yet another strange way to
multiply now when I was in school I had
to memorize up to the 12 times 12 tables
now I figured at standards day for
students to memorize up to their 10
ten tables but actually you only need to
go up to your five times five tables
because your fingers will get you up to
ten by ten pretty easily let me show you
how I'm going to work out seven times
eight with my fingers goes as follows
again quirky watch out a closed fist
represents five to make it seven I'm
going to add two more digits six seven
the closed fist represents five and to
make it my other number eight I'm going
to add three more digits six seven eight
alright so there's a number seven
there's the number eight so far so good
now I want to work out seven times eight
this quirky method says count each
finger up as worth ten I've got five
fingers up a total ten five ten is fifty
and multiplies the fingers that are down
I've got three down on this side two
down this side three times two is six I
claim the after seven times eight is
fifty-six and it is crazy crazy okay
maybe that was coincidence let's do
another example let's do say six times
nine closed fist is five to make it six
add one more digit closed fist is five
to make it nine at four more digits all
right each digit up is worth ten so
currently five digits up that's fifty
and multiplies the digits down for down
on this side one down this side four
times one is four I claim the answer to
6 times 9 is 54 crazy alright alright
little bit freaky I've been doing yet
another one why not this is this is kind
of fun let's do it I know eight times
eight close this is five to make it
eight three more digits close this is
five to make it eight
three more digits each digit up is worth
1060 multiply the digits down two down
two down two times two is four 8 times 8
is 64 in same in fact I can go even
crazier instead of working with just ten
fingers ten digits let me work with my
fingers and toes let's work with all 20
digits so my rules gonna change little
bit it goes as follows let's do say 17
times 18 and we know the answers 206
let's see how it works I'm gonna use all
my fingers and toes on my right side
everything down is now worth ten through
ten digits down
to make this 17 as five more toes which
you can't see under my shoe and two more
fingers so I've got seven digits up ten
and seven digits up makes 17 on my other
side everything down is worth ten to
make it 18 on some trouble balancing it
goes five toes up which you can't see
and three more fingers right now I've
got eight digits up on my left side that
makes 10 and 8 is 18 so here's the
number 17 it's number 18
all right the rule this time is each
digit up is now worth 20 so I'm working
with all 20 digits so I've got seven up
on the side eight up on this side I've
got 15 digits up each worth 20 that
makes three hundred and multiply the
digits down there's only actually three
down on this side and two down on this
side three times two is six I claimed
seventeen done 18 is 306 and we know it
is Wow all right so the real question is
why does this work
that's the little juicy part here so
let's go back to ordinary finger mullick
Asian we're closed fist represents five
and let's look at say seven times eight
again all right
so can you slowly seven it's a closed
fist plus two raised fingers and eight
is a closed fist with three raised
fingers but now I don't want to do the
wristlet ixodes specific number so let's
think about my left hand as a fingers up
to represent the number five plus a so
here's five plus two makes seven in
general be five plus a and the number on
my right this caused B fingers raised so
this represents the number five plus B
over here it's really 5 plus 3 is 8 but
in general let's think 5 plus B so I'm
now going to do the argument in full
generality and see how this works
all right now so the number of fingers
down on my right hand if there are a
fingers up and the five fingers in total
that means five minus a is the formula
for the number of fingers down and on my
other side five minus B is the former
for the number of fingers down five
lines a fingers down here five minus B
fingers down here being very general
again now we're trying to compute the
product
times eight in abstract terms that's
five plus a times five plus B and the
crazy method I said says to do the
following count each finger raised as
worth 10 their a fingers up on the side
B fingers up in this side so that's 10 a
and 10 B so the fingers up give the
answer 10 a plus 10 B again be fully
general here and then we multiply the
fingers that are down the counselor down
are left and the counselor down on the
right there would be five minus a times
five minus B now the magic claim is that
for our product five plus eight times
five plus B equals what we just did
which is 10 a and which 10 a and 10 B
plus five minus a times five minus B all
right but we can do this this is a
little bit of algebra we can actually
expand this out and make sense of it
let's use a rectangle to compute the
original product first five plus a times
five plus B and we have this picture and
we see in this picture that we get a 25
we get a five times a and we get a five
times B and we get an a times B so we
have the formula for the product five
plus eight times five plus B is 25 plus
5 a is 5 B plus a B but but the crazy
method says no no no don't go with that
formula go this one instead 10 a plus 10
B plus 5 minus a times 5 minus B 4 so is
that the same thing well what you do
let's work it out let's look at that
crazy formula and see if it gives the
same answer in the end so let's first
work out the 5 minus a times 5 minus B
part and then at a 10 a and edit NB to
it next all right so here's the
rectangle 4 5 minus a times 5 minus B
what lots of pieces are but notice one
piece is negative a times negative B and
we know that must be positive a B so we
get 5 minus a times 5 minus B is 25
minus 5 a minus five B plus a B now we
still put it at the 10 a and the 10 B to
this so let's do that
25 minus 5 a minus 5 B plus a B
plus 10a now plus 10d as well all right
so that's the general formulas the crazy
method but look at this general formula
we see that 10a and negative 5a together
make positive 5a and tend to be a
negative five be together make positive
5b so counting each raised finger is
worth 10 and adding the product of the
counts of fingers down actually gives
the answer 25 plus 5a 5b plus a B which
is exactly the same formula that we had
we worked out the product 5a plus 5b the
two formulas Nash
exactly this method is guaranteed to
work absolutely brilliant for fingers
and toes each digit raised is now worth
20 and he multiplies the counts of
digits that are down this corresponds to
establishing the formula 10 plus a times
10 plus B equals 20 days 20 B's plus 10
minus a times 10 minus B and one can
prove this formula is valid in exactly
the same way the visual of the rectangle
will make it clear so today we made good
use of area for helping us make sense of
multiplication so let's actually take
some time next lecture and focus on area
for spell and make sense of all the
things we like to believe are true about
it so I'll see you next time